[Music]
on this tuesday night the taliban now
back in full control of afghanistan
a new uncertain era begins we're trying
very hard to get the
taliban to agree to allow people to
leave safely how many canadians have
been left behind
ballooning dead how much should
canadians worry about balancing the
books
he spent 11 years as calgary's mayor
i talked to nahed nenshi about politics
alberta's future and the surge in covet
cases the premier showed up on the
proverbial aircraft carrier unveiled the
mission accomplished banner and then
went on vacation
and rapid melt in the rockies
it's very depressing why glaciers are
retreating at a record rate
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
we are in calgary alberta tonight a
place that owes its prosperity to oil
and gas and like economies everywhere
was brought to its knees by the pandemic
good evening and thanks for joining us
politically this is conservative country
the liberals were shut out of alberta
and saskatchewan in the last federal
election since then simmering anger
towards the trudeau government has grown
but there's unhappiness too about
conservative premier jason kenney who
has the lowest approval rating of any
premier there is an unsettled feeling
here we'll get to all of that in a
moment but we begin in afghanistan where
for the first time in two decades there
are no us troops on the ground the
taliban is now in full control
this was kabul airport today after the
hasty american retreat taliban fighters
declared victory on the tarmac and took
stock of all that was left behind the
final hours of a lost war the u.s handed
the country over to the same islamist
leaders it toppled in 2001.
with the americans gone and evacuation
flights now finished thousands of
afghans who helped canada and other u.s
allies are stuck the taliban says it
will allow afghans with proper documents
to leave the country but that is no
guarantee
redmond shannon has our top story
tonight
major general chris donohue's name is
now burned into history the last
american to leave afghanistan after a
two decade two trillion dollar war
158 canadian soldiers were among the
tens of thousands who died including
almost 50 000 afghan civilians alone
u.s president joe biden saying he made
the decision to leave now but there was
plenty blame to go around for the
disastrous and deadly exit
that assumption
that the afghan government would be able
to hold on
for a period of time beyond military
drawdown
turned out not to be accurate canada is
committing to resettle twenty thousand
of the most vulnerable more than two
thousand were flown out in canadian
aircraft in the past two weeks we now
know five thousand more who left on u.s
planes will resettle in canada too a
canadian veterans group says it knows of
at least 5 700 applicants who are still
in afghanistan
and the canadian government says more
than 1200 canadian citizens permanent
residents or family members also remain
for them cold comfort from ottawa stay
put because the situation at this point
is uncertain and as we have described
we're trying very hard to get the
taliban to agree to allow people to
leave safely many are living in fear one
former interpreter told global news the
taliban knows where his family is
staying
one afghan who may end up in canada is
tv news anchor bahishta argand she
interviewed a taliban spokesman just two
days after the fall of kabul she now
hopes they follow through on their
promises to respect the rights of women
and girls if they do what they promised
i think one day we have a very beautiful
and good afghanistan
her compatriots and the wider world are
waiting too redmond shannon global news
london
canada still has a huge role to play in
what happens to the people of
afghanistan the only escape route now
for those who want to leave is a
dangerous journey to a land border and
who knows what will happen there
afghanistan came up on the campaign
trail again today our chief political
correspondent david aiken is traveling
with the liberals david
well donna liberal leader justin trudeau
continues to be dogged by questions
about afghanistan on the campaign trail
and today he was pressed to commit to
funding veterans canadian veterans who
in many cases are digging into their own
pockets trying to help those trying to
flee the taliban as this government did
with syrian refugees we will continue to
step up and work with all canadians to
make sure we are giving all the
opportunities and all the support
to afghans fleeing violence trudeau and
his ministers have also said they are
working with countries like pakistan to
process refugees who cross into that
country nonetheless the trudeau
government remains vague when it comes
to specifics about how canada will help
now as for campaign announcements the
liberals are promising to transfer 1.2
billion dollars more each year for the
next five years to provinces and
indigenous communities for mental health
programs
i'm abigail beeman with the ndp campaign
in burnaby jugmeat singh again focused
on housing promising to boost the
taxable portion of capital gains profits
on people who flip homes from 50 to 75
percent very wealthy investors are using
the housing market like a stock market
the liberals are also promising a home
flipping tax but have come under fire
including from the ndp as documents show
one of their vancouver candidates has
bought and sold 41 properties since 2005
turning 5 million in profit yes you
heard that right 41. late tuesday talib
nor muhammad issued a statement
acknowledging he had quote business
activities that would have been impacted
by the liberal plan but he is fully
supportive of it new democrats are
feeling optimistic in week three they
have a full slate of candidates
nationally and just over half are women
in bc the party is targeting at least
four seats they think they can pick up
battling incumbents who are liberal
conservative and green
i'm mercedes stevenson covering the
conservative campaign in ottawa where
aaron o'toole zeroed in on the
historically high debt and deficit after
unprecedented pandemic spending
o'toole says if elected a conservative
government would balance the budget
within 10 years we will grow the economy
so that we can get back to balance in a
responsible and equitable way without
cuts
that is our plan the tories are steering
clear of proposing cuts arguing they can
pay down the debt by growing the economy
and slowing down the government spending
canadians have seen under the liberals
but if a growthy economy plan sounds
familiar it's because it is that's also
the liberal strategy for getting out of
the red the tories are trying to
capitalize on personal finance concerns
but the emphatic no cuts approach says
something about the mood among voters
donna
all right mercedes stevenson at ottawa
thanks here in alberta there was a
sliver of good economic news today the
projected deficit is lower than expected
7.8 billion instead of the 18 billion
projected in the last budget the
government credits a partial economic
recovery from covid19 and a rebound in
the energy sector but alberta's debt the
total amount owing has never been higher
more than 100 billion dollars and
canada's debt is now more than a
trillion dollars tonight jeff semple
looks at how worried canadians should be
about all that spending
this university of calgary student just
spent four months looking for a
part-time job and to say the least it's
been really tough the fourth year
economics major wants to be part of
alberta's energy transition but says the
pandemic has made the province's
prospects even worse the ballooning debt
is really getting out of control i'm
extremely worried for my future over the
course of covid19 canada's deficit has
grown faster than any other developed
country the debt forecast to hit 1.6
trillion dollars this year
but unlike election campaigns passed no
major party is promising to balance the
books for at least a decade in the short
term that's of course quite
understandable the pandemic has resulted
in an extraordinary level of
expenditures economists largely agree
the pandemic spending spree is both
necessary and manageable thanks in part
to record low interest rates government
debt is not like household debt
governments can borrow over a very long
time span they don't necessarily ever
need to fully repay that debt
the economy is like a cup the bigger it
is the more debt it can carry this year
canada's debt to gdp ratio is forecast
to hit 51 percent far less than during
the 90s or the second world war back
then the economy was smaller and
drowning in debt
during the 1940s the government sent
more than a million canadians to fight
to pay for it canada borrowed boatloads
of
cash after the war interest rates were
also low and canada's economy emerged
stronger than ever so might history
repeat we are in almost exactly the
opposite situation now economist ian lee
was born in 1953 after his father
returned from the war one of four
siblings which was about the average for
the time canada's birth rate today is
1.5
we're almost at the other end of that
continuum where the boomers are moving
into retirement lee says that aging
population will send health care costs
soaring and our debt will make it harder
to pay those bills we're not going to be
able to borrow our way
through this this former bank of canada
governor says the next government should
reduce spending and invest in a
low-carbon economy we face a very real
challenge in this country going forward
as we have to make these investments and
that transition he says is particularly
challenging in alberta i don't want to
see
governments just up and abandoning
alberta and leaving it to hang out to
dry
justin gotta was born and raised in
calgary but says he isn't sure how long
he can afford to stay
jeff semple global news
one transformation plan for the oil and
gas industry coming up how companies
want ottawa's help to make it happen
we are on the traditional territories of
the people of the treaty 7 region in
southern alberta the city of calgary is
also home to metis nation of alberta
region three
we're back in a moment
[Music]
the oil and gas industry still employs
hundreds of thousands of people in
alberta and contributes billions towards
canada's gdp but the world is moving
away from fossil fuels and alberta has
to adapt one plan is to scale up carbon
capture as heather urex west explains
canada's five biggest oil producers have
a plan but want billions in taxpayer
investment to pull it off
since last summer about 70 percent of
the carbon dioxide produced at the nwr
sturgeon refinery has been pumped back
into the ground it's carried to a
storage facility via a co2 pipeline that
took more than a decade and hundreds of
millions of government dollars to build
without carbon capture and storage we
will never be able to beat our
commitments
but before this technology can make a
real difference for canada's emission
reduction targets carbon capture and
storage projects need to be scaled up
drastically and fast in june canada's
five largest oil production companies
canadian natural sonovas energy imperial
meg energy and suncor announced the oil
sands pathway to net zero initiative
it's a plan to get the industry to net
zero emissions by 2050 anchored by a
multi-billion dollar carbon capture and
storage plan one that would see an
underground carbon corridor built
between the company's northern alberta
oil sands facilities and an underground
storage hub near cold lake alberta
there's nobody better nobody better to
do this than the oil and gas companies
but it's it's going to take some time in
order to put this together i think as
they say it may take a decade or two to
to make that all happen the proposal
would reduce emissions by 68 megatons by
2050 that represents about nine percent
of canada's total greenhouse gas
emissions but at 75 billion dollars the
plan is pricey and the industry is not
prepared to foot the bill alone
the energy giants declined our request
for an interview until after the
election but in an interview before the
election call with the financial times
synovus ceo alex porbay said ottawa
should pay up to 70 percent more than 50
billion dollars though a spokesperson
for the group now says following the
election we look forward to working with
the federal government to develop an
achievable plan
some analysts believe federal funds
would be better spent elsewhere
particularly if as many are predicting
we see the global demand for oil peak
within 20 years it would make more sense
to take that additional
public funding and put it towards
industries that are going to be part of
the economy for
in a carbon constrained future for years
to come fossil fuels may no longer be
the energy source of the distant future
but without a significant green
transformation the short-term viability
of canada's energy sector is also now at
stake heather urex west global news
calgary
[Music]
ahead the dying glacier why an iconic
site in the canadian rockies will soon
be history
you may have heard of the pito glacier
in the canadian rockies the summer's
record heat waves and fires have
triggered an unprecedented melt the
pitot glacier is now retreating 10 times
faster than it has in the last half
century
jamie dull went to find out why and what
scientists are now projecting
it's horrific to see this almost
unrecognizable from one year ago
few glaciers in the world have been
monitored as long as this one this
picture dates back to the early 1900s
since then peter glacier has receded
three and a half kilometers
dr john palmeroy first stepped foot on
this ice in 2008 he came to better
understand the hydrology of pedo glacier
and its neighbors but he never imagined
it could melt away in his lifetime
he's horrified we're basically seeing
the glacier disintegrate very rapidly
before our eyes
and i think we'll be documenting the end
of this glacier
over my career now
this season the ice melts are the
highest ever recorded we could lose
about seven meters of ice off the
glacier this year and the hundreds are
burning wildfires making it even worse
so a lot of the soot from the wildfires
has landed on the glaciers and darkened
them up and then the algae and the
bacteria and viruses start growing on
this stuff
and it darkens the glacier and you see
where it's accumulated here the ice is
melted faster than where there's less of
it over here
just 13 years ago this lake behind me
was covered in ice but what's even more
astonishing is if i were to be standing
on the surface 60 years ago i would have
been 200 meters higher i called the area
at the top of the glacier the graveyard
because that's where the glacier goes to
die that's really where we see the
fastest change the most change it's
melting really fast it's changing really
fast
and it's it's very depressing
pito is part of the headwaters to the
north saskatchewan river a life source
for so many across the prairie provinces
you know it's not
impossible to imagine
if we're losing ice at the rate that the
petal glacier is losing ice this year
that our rivers would run dry
in august or september and this is like
grievously serious for the future of
life on the prairies the world as we
know it is being transformed as we watch
this is not just affecting water supply
and irrigation and hydropower it's uh
it's affecting the very nature of the
canadian rockies and what they are
that's very sad i think
dr pomeroy projects peta will be gone
within a decade yet another casualty of
a changing climate we're reaching a
range of conditions outside of which our
species developed
and so i hope we can preserve all of
this
jamie dog global news have national park
i wanted to um show you something if you
don't mind taking a peek at these so
this is um 2010 i don't know if you
remember i was so thin
[Music]
next i catch up with nahed nenshi after
11 years what's changed for calgary's
first muslim mayor
[Music]
eleven years ago it was national news
when nahed nenshi was elected mayor of
calgary with a master's degree from
harvard he was the first muslim mayor of
a big canadian city and it was a signal
the calgary was more diverse and
cosmopolitan than a lot of people
thought i first interviewed him back in
2010 since then he's dealt with a
massive flood a severe economic downturn
a climate crisis the pandemic and an
increasingly toxic political atmosphere
if i have to have a quick lunch there's
only one fast food place near my office
and nowadays i am not allowed to walk to
the a w by myself why not
too many you never know who's going to
talk to you you never know who's going
to confront you in that one block walk
between my office and the a w where is
all that anger come from is it the
pandemic it's not the last year this has
been growing and growing and growing for
at least the last five years
partially is the weaponization of social
media and false information and
narratives part of it is politicians
who
have played with fire who have thought
if i do a little bit of this
it'll help my vote
not realizing what they were unleashing
or maybe realizing what they were
unleashing so remember in 2015 well
before trump
we had a federal election here in canada
where the government of the time was
running an explicitly anti-muslim
campaign
the barbaric cultural practices hotline
the niqab ban
and so it's a bit disingenuous to now
say oh i don't know where this came from
because when you blow the dog whistle
the dogs come
let me ask you about covid uh cases are
rising here in alberta going up fast
hospitals are beginning to fill up again
as well
is the policy do you think just let her
rip and and will deal with the
consequences listen i'm as shocked as
anyone the premier showed up on the
proverbial aircraft carrier unveiled the
mission accomplished banner and then
went on vacation we thought he had
solved kovitt
of course we knew he hadn't solved covet
and it is actually quite shocking the
dereliction of duty here by the
provincial government premier kenny has
not been seen in public for some time
not participating in the federal
campaign at all what do you make of that
well it's obvious why he's not
participating in the federal campaign
you know in the previous federal
campaign he wasn't in alberta very much
because he thought he'd be very helpful
to the conservatives everywhere and it's
clear that you know political fortunes
wane and wave
and in this case he would probably be a
major detriment to mr o'toole's campaign
that said i'd sure liked him to be at
work here in alberta
and i'd sure like to see some real work
being done so parents can feel safe
about their kids going back to school
what everybody is trying to figure out
is how does alberta get back on its feet
how do you transition from oil and gas
to renewables how long does that take
who's got the best plan for it so here's
the critical piece
it's not about alberta getting back on
its feet it's about canada getting back
on its feet the federal government will
never balance its budget unless alberta
is operating on all cylinders
and so it's important to all of us
and it frustrates me when i hear
canadians in other parts of the country
saying ah let them freeze
they'll sort themselves out not
realizing the impact that it's having on
the entire country there's nobody in any
one of those buildings
in those oil company headquarters and
energy company centers that doesn't
believe in climate change
there's nobody there that doesn't
believe that we're in the midst of a
very very generational
pocal change
transition that we've got to get through
but ultimately those are also the
smartest people in energy in the world
in those buildings and there is no
reason that that downtown that we're
looking at cannot be the world's center
of clean energy there is no reason why
we cannot be leaders in the climate
crisis rather than it being something
that happens to us
thanks so much thank you
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen we leave you
tonight with the soaring sights of
calgary's skyline i'll see you again
thursday from edmonton as we make our
way across canada during the federal
election campaign
thanks for watching bye
[Music]